Manage vulnerabilities more efficiently in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
You can now increase or decrease the issue severity ratings in your scan results.
First, navigate to the results of a recent scan.
Click View Issues.
Let's select an issue that wasn't marked as a high priority by the scanner.
In the new Manage Issue drop-down menu, you can now choose Edit Issue Severity.
From here, you can change the severity rating.
Let's change this to High.
You can also document your changes, leaving comments to provide context for your colleagues.
But what if you've investigated an issue and determined it's an accepted risk?
Let's go back to our scan results and choose an issue to edit.
On the drop-down menu, click Mark Issue as Accepted Risk.
You can choose whether to apply this change individually or across other issues of the same type.
Like changing issue severity, you can leave notes to document your changes.
Manage your vulnerabilities your way with Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
Click the link below to find out more.
Click the link below.